ciao readers benvenuti in un nuovissimo
v
[Musica]
girovagando per il web ho trovato dei
video di alcune ragazze che si
ricostruiscono le unghie utilizzando
degli elementi come dire un po inusuali
ecco credo di non aver mai visto delle
unghie così strane e così particolari
per non dire agghiaccianti ma sono gusti
ma bando alle ciance partiamo subito con
le prime unghie più strane del mondo ok
abbiamo un unghia una mano all interno
della quale ci sono dei tondini di
metallo e li ha messi sull'unghia
triarico su di un attimo p's ok quindi
mette come ha fatto a fare la fila di
tondini poi mette il gel sopra clima e
giustamente poi si ritrova lunga con
dentro questi fantastici tondini di
metallo
ho un po paura
cioè se questo è l'inizio o povero per
la fine qui abbiamo una zucchina a no
dietro c'è l'augurio e la buccia
dell'anguria giustamente cosa fai per
non buttarla defy è la ricostruzione
quindi ovviamente ricopre con il gel e
poi li ma ok toglie le parti in sé c'è
clima di nuovo taglia e magicamente poi
c'è anche la decorazione ovviamente
quindi è una sorta di anguria allungata
sulla sua unghia estiva credo che a
maggio luglio go
beh quest'estate potrei eventualmente
pensarci una cosa così un po
[Musica]
non so come spiegare andiamo avanti
no ragazzi stop romita di giura
all'inizio non pensavo che fosse una
mano finta e immaginate
ma perché tra l'altro andiamo avanti
banana è stata una banana la buccia e
molle to stop
come fa a c'è come ha fatto teneva così
lunga e molle cieco qual è la base sulla
quale adagiato la banana e soprattutto
la banana
chissà dopo un po ok la sigillata con il
gel ma io credo che non sia proprio
profumata come ricostruzione poi brutta
socialmente un'arancia che cos'è a
perfetto la mette tutta la buccia
giustamente della rancia che fai non la
butti ve devo dirvi questo l'effetto
finale abbastanza carino mi piace anche
che alla fine dice io comunque con
questo mi ha così affilata l'arancia la
pro così c'è proprio la spacco con
l'unghia ci sta abbiamo un borro cos'è
porro erba cipollina
vabbè sento sento la puzza da qui
andiamo per set taglia la radice dalla
base e ci sono le radici keys mano
[Musica]
poi prende il gel e copre questa merda
clima e lasciate radici che spuntano
ragazzi io forse vomito no veramente c'è
questa è la frase del del video io non
ci posso credere
cioè così bello ricostruirsi le unghie
fatte bene perché devi mettere un poro
una c nair baci pose cipolla che cos'è
il cipollotto certa idea della puzza ma
perché ma poi la domanda è se le tiene o
no queste unghie ma a proposito di
cipolle una bella cipolla rossa di
tropea
ok quindi pianta la cipolla nei lunghi
al ricovero il gel tagli ovviamente lati
la lima bene e poi c'è anche questo
effetti un po tipo petali di rose che
non si capisce come la ricreato perché
se la fatta partire da metà unghia come
falli inizialmente sarà magari
un'applicazione successiva d'immagine
lei che prende come fosse un foglio
d'oro prende la pellicina della cipolla
seramente ii e crea questo effetto così
bellissimo bella dai è il fusillo a il
rosso alla base dell'unghia e ketchup e
sangue come se l'è procurato questo
effetto pasta al pomodoro sull'unghia e
lo chiederemo abbiamo un tappo di
sughero una corteccia che cos'è una a
cannella beh qui passiamo già qualcosa
di più profumato meno male ha deciso che
ha capito che con le cipolle c'era un po
di puzza così nell'aria e quindi ha
deciso di optare per la cannella che tra
l'altro io amo particolarmente
quindi se la mette di solito
procedimento scende bene il gel molto
precisa poi del clima bla bla bla e
diciamo che la forma poteva ecco
migliorarla
che cos'è questo rettangolo
ma la domanda che farà veramente l'unico
tecnica o e come se io mettessi a fare
la cretina con degli oggetti sulle
unghie e lo chiederemo a va beh
mancavano le arachidi mancavano le rate
di cosa la apre ok la infila su lunga
piace affatto
fai un giro a apre l'arachide columbia
vedete come se fosse uno schiaccianoci
in quelli gente quindi però lei se l'era
già ricostruite con quella che mi serve
interessante vedere il procedimento
allora abbiamo fatto vari i frutti
l'arancia l'anguria mancava ovviamente
l'ananas coda file non per non buttare
la buccia tela butti sull'unghia la
linee bene tu tu tu tu tu e dai
bellissima non la vorreste voi lunga
così automaticamente fa il compleanno
cosa succede le candeline una volta che
le sono file multi no perché c'è la
nostra amica che prende la candelina la
taglia a metà se la applica su lunga mi
raccomando lasciate la parte dove c'è
appunto la lo spago per accenderla
perché perché qui non lo fa vedere
giustamente perché ci faccio un altro
video che adesso cercheremo ma se tu ti
applichi la candelina la puoi accendere
ma poi vuoi mettere a un compleanno
accendere su una banalissima torta
invece fare tanti auguri
ho capito capite la genialità adesso mi
è chiara no no ragazzi allora questa
questa persona e passa questa persona e
farsi non posso parlare questo video
abbiamo riso abbiamo scherzato con i
cibi gli oggetti ma no ragazzi meno
interiormente
no non ce la faccio devo togliere
scusate
va beh ne abbiamo viste delle belle in
realtà delle bruttissime e credo che
anche voi ed a casa vi siete spaventati
insieme a me ma sono gusti quindi fatemi
sapere qui sotto due cose quella che
abbia fatto più schifo è quella che
magari magari vi piacerebbe fare perché
sì perché vi piacciono le cose un po
estrema quindi fatemelo sapere qui sotto
fatemi sapere se vi è piaciuta questa
tipologia di video perché potrebbero
essercene altri io vi mando un bacione e
soprattutto vi faccio vedere le mie
unghie che sono belle non come quelli
ciao adoro
[Musica]